citizens of the reject Nation everybody's been
saying I don't say that and I don't but now I
have a shirt to remind me you know what I just
remembered don't you have your film always Lola
out now available it's coming out November
28th yeah wow that's pre-order it on Apple
now oh my God I know what I'm doing November 28th
pre-ordering and then trying to find time to watch
your movie that's what I'm going to do you're very
nice I'm going to cry I told Greg I asked Greg if
I could mention at the end and then he brought
up at the top because he knows more you guys are
watching and that's really sweet thank you you're
welcome anyway you you it but we're doing trolls
how are you going to not troll me we're going to
do a trolls movie and you're going to be nice it's
opposite day apparently you know we've been keep
this sincerity is making me uncomfortable me too
I'm so uncomfortable we've been keeping things
very local but I think it's time for us to go on
a world tour I see what you're doing now things
have been really locally lies but now it's time
to take our trolls on a world tour give me
the mic take me to Italy that's what we're
shooting this right now we have green screen in
the background it's kind of crazy that you built
this set in Florence anyway I'm excited for this
we love the first one surprisingly yeah we both
loved it but it's been a long time you didn't
watch nothing but horror movies here now and
make you watch this cuz the third one's coming
out and if you guys are excited like comment
subscribe hit that notification do all that good
stuff tell Greg how much nicer he is when he's
not Troll And if you're super sexy okay let's see
if you're the sexiest of rejects then you should
sync up with your own copy because that's what
the patrons do where you watch along with your
own copy on patreon nailed it from the camera
it looks like you don't want to look at me no
I have notes I don't want to look at you when
I said no guys go over there that's where Greg
and John cover several shows exclusively with
reaction highlights and watch Longs included
you ready for some trolls yeah can we shout
out the shirts too we'll do that after well
look at them you want to do it later yeah I'll
do it after okay we'll do the shout out after
word wow I haven't seen most of these most of
what was that not just 25 images of trolls I
there bunch of different movies yeah wake up
rocks oh sweet animation oh we loved this two
trolls one was named Poppy hey how's it going
the other was named Branch recap together they
saved the world poppy became Queen Branch found
his true colors that's right I forgot all about
that was gray right yeah boom and that was
pretty cute right not to me I'm the type of
cloud that goes for that's real Poppy and Branch
didn't know is that their world was a lot bigger
than they knew like a lot lot lot lot bigger oh
they're going to go exploring this time I told you
we're on a world tour Greg is that pixelated
what is this it's like a puzzle piece we're
underwater which oan oh is this around
the world it's why we getting da Punk one
more time I should have said it with you
I'm really upset about that I'm so upset
right now I'm sorry we'll get over
it eventually we going to Cate all
right let's blast this family love and music
family love and music they're naming their
themes got a stay
frame let me see you jump wait for it wait for it
viruses yeah but look how vibrant the viruses are
virus hypnotic tech one more time going
on Sal who is singing this uh I have no
idea [Music] Usher I love Usher Let me just
take care of this real quick okay I recognize
that voice who is that Rock Tour what are you
doing invading here are there like a heavy
metal what's going on there he is they are
like heavy metal of the Techno trolls right
who's asking Queen Barb of the Hard Rock
trolls huh I'm here to take your string
bro damn shots on this are way more Vivid if
we lose our string we lose our
music you mean your bleeps and
bloops yeah that's not music yes it is whose voice
is this Greg this is somebody very famous yeah I'm
gonna definitely hear you you got [Music] it oh
hell yeah all right let's go oh he banged his head
against the drum banged his nose and everything
I loved that here I am rocking Like a Hurricane
I love how much more physical and visual
these everything is by the end of my world
tour we're all going to have the same
Vibe we're all going to be one nation
of trolls under Rock no it's about variety
who's ready to rock I am are you not I'm
ready to rock but she's villainous but she
said who's ready to rock you always have
to answer me okay I'm sorry well now now
it's just Girls Just Want to Have Fun woke
[Music] up
okay oh they changed the lyrics trolls just
W to have fun was this Anna Kendrick yeah
okay to get away from the world till I
had my life Changed by a beautiful a I
love how it's a different rendition yeah
but they're best friends but he loves her
I knew it I saw this coming oh he's going
to try to tell her she's the one I don't
know that Anna's reciprocates
she might have friend-zoned you
[Music]
buddy I hope they end up together by
the end I think so I think she loves
him too but it might take it might take her
a moment to know her true feelings she's had
a lot going on Greg prepared an agenda for
the day I hope it says singing dancing and
hugging ow owow what we do every day yeah
good times good G we have a good time Good
Times They budget this movie threw down on
different types of Landscapes and everything
and dimensions oh what's happening
here like turning into stickers guy
Diamond what's wrong I'm having a baby we on
jumpsuit what are the implications I don't
know I guess they're trolls so what should I
name him H but why do they need to come there
tiny diamond tiny diamond daddy M my body's
made of glitter and I'll throw it in your face
tired oh I love the song talk
about variety they're going
like rock disco they had rap they're
going around the world oh and we're
back imagine being to walk with your hair that's
[Music] amazing seriously the vibrancy through
the roof on this one tiny diamond welcome to the
family little buddy thanks a puppy and thanks to
this silver haired daddy of [Laughter] M uh
poppy there's something I was hoping to ask
you I I mean pick your moment this is a good
moment any moment's a good moment any moment
yeah I know women better than you she's a
troll I I I I wanted to tell you that well
she's disinterested you're crushing it at this
queen thing oh branch thank you a being a good
Queen is the most important thing in the world to
me other than being your friend ouch dude I feel
your dog is my whole life what other than last
few years fo for most of my life one of us is
utterly alone and the other found an incredible
wife whose life is this as a guy I really
relate GoPro I thought they ended up together in
the last movie didn't they share like one little
almost kiss or something gotcha it's in my it's
in my I know it's not but the animation looks more
stop motion there you go calm down good boy the
attention to detail on their movement yeah I mean
why do you think they would have changed that add
more Dimension to it to Queen Popp challenge Barb
the queen of rock announces her one nation under
Rock World Tour it's nothing it means nothing at
all go there you go he's doing the exact same
thing these other trolls aren't like us they're
different different like Lesley not being me
skyscraper troll yeah different like me they're
different in ways you can't even imagine I think
skyscraper troll are all sitting on each other I
think there's the physics behind you makes you
want to snap your fingers tap your Tong to and
wiggle your butt that's our music That's What
Makes Us pop trolls we have to learn to accept
others though they dance different why some of
them can't even begin to grasp the concept of
hammer time they all look worried rock and roll is
the devil's music so we'll see what happens in the
beginning there was silence until one day someone
made a sound our ancestors were so inspired by
the sound they took six strings the power to
control all mus they could play anything had
like energy representation country Hard Rock and
pop and every kind of music in between there was
something for everyone it was one big party
Universal this is actually very cool trolls
became intolerant of each other's music there's
like a political undertone to this they fought
over what kind of music the strings would play
the elders realized there was but one solution
each tribe would take a string segregation and
go their separate ways hey segregation go a
long way man techno country rock classical
Funk and us the pops oh my God we're going
to unite the Nations techno got its own one
Jesus that's why we need to keep our strings
safe the pop music string wow pop you didn't know
about any of this yeah it's just been chilling
there and you never knew but I don't get why
techno has its own what is techno's string I
don't think you're looking enough into this I
think you should read deeper into it okay I'll
try I've been preparing for this day for years we
run you're assuming the worst about someone you
haven't even met you're not listening to me you're
not listening to me oh is already a great message
you don't know anything about the other trolls
well we know they're trolls Branch look around
troll Village everybody's different even us this
is a surprisingly mature direction did you hear
something stop trying to change the subject look
being queen means having a lot of power and it's
my job to use it for good responsibility what
do you think she should do right now she should
get to do I think she's on the right path I think
she's on a solo journey and and her father should
be communicating more I think she's a little bit
of naive to the obstacles but I feel like in the
end her message is going to convey and I guess
I'm with I'm coming with you damn right you are
I really didn't want to go by myself there we go
she really needed a friend no they're lovas this
one looks a little bit like me We have the same
hat wait what does he represent reg hip-hop I'm
trying to stereotype him in a way that's not off
I don't know crazy oh that's how I really want to
know who this [Music] is this looks like Mad Max
this is the trolls place that I would have wanted
to ended up I mean it looks pretty badass I
get why you want to live under this nation
walls [Music] the the a crazy train I wonder if
this is the first time a lot of kids heard that
song yeah I got the Techno string who knew world
domination could be so much fun techno's the worst
of the strings to get though my dude that is a
subjective take it really is when I was in college
I would have liked it only four more strings to
go so the guitar is like the Infinity Stones yeah
there you are dad I got the Techno string what's
a string again don't you remember the plan I don't
remember oh great idea man the trolls under one
music our music that is too much control man
you're not understanding the power of the strings
I can't look at them as villains because they're
my people they want to eliminate other sounds
sucks to suck Rock will rule [Music] try one of
these it's either pink or Kelly Clarkson or
somebody like that it's some big pop star I
think oh oh my god oh hello sorry I couldn't help
myself you know how I am around cotton candy and
there's James Gordon it's the only reason he
would return as to get more screen time weapons
oh well violence never solves a problem brand good
good reflexes in case we need them we won't need
them unless these pointy sticks help you listen
or these rocks help you put yourself in someone
else's shoes and what about these Knuckles they're
brass knuckles we don't even know what's out
there wait dude you may
want to take a look at this
it's very hooville I do like the Embrace of the
world a lot more actually surprisingly feels
like a natural progression for this universe
great transition yeah that really was actually
whoa something gnarly happened here gnarly bro
identify yourself are you nice or are you mean
we're really nice yeah but not too nice okay a
so this was the Techno universe that they took
over the string from it used to be called Symphony
Ville where the classical music troll oh classical
music no techville was underwater yeah yeah yeah
you're right so this was the first string they
got which was Symphony it was a place where all of
the classical music trolls could live in Perfect
Harmony I don't want to get rid of classical
I love class classical how heavenly it looks
beautiful but then Queen Barb showed up I'm here
for your string we will not go [Music] quietly
have you seen Scott Pilgrim versus the world yes
there's a bit of that flare to it too our music
she took everyone yeah you can't take people's
Music Man someone's really had a change of heart
I love rock and roll but it's kind of rude
to make rock the villain it' been funnier if
classical was a villain they're like up yeah but
then people would have like seen into it as like
a you know conservative thing our string is safe
what you brought your string you said this could
be handled with hugs how are we going to hug our
way out of this one when am I going to learn to
stay away from the cotton candy that's why he was
on the ship right right right promise that I will
protect you no matter what pinky promise you know
you can't go back on a pinky promise never did
never will in high school we used to call it RP
for Roxy promise it was a non-broken promise from
anybody I would never break a promise RP that
would happen kind of I would be like [Music]
RP a pinky promise I guess pinky promises are
a serious thing will you come with us someone
has to rebuild and Penny Whistle is that woodwin
for the job it almost sounds like Marcel shell
some people tell me my head's too big for my body
and I just look at them and say compared to what
what did they do to you my hairy little baby
they bedazzled it pop trolls dear Barb oh no
I have tons of great great party ideas maybe
you and I can even be best friends I already
have a ton of friends like Carol right Carol
oh oh she's just lonely and taking it out on
people oh my
God the lyrics empd worst of all
it crawls into your head like an ID
world I need that pop string and I know who's
going to help me wow it's really a movie about
communication Jazz the smooth jazz troll the
ratone trolls the K-pop [Music] game the yoders
so are these people who are not in one place
oh yeah they they're like Freelancers yeah I
mean K-pop is straight up pop but but better
yeah it is great whoever brings me Queen poppy
gets to keep their very own music in their
very own territory right over here wow you
are not a good ruler maybe it's a younger pop
star like uh Billy ish or something I can't
figure out who the hell it is I know and
you probably won't until the credits start
rolling oh we about to get country
music I like this song for Big Hair is just
incredible I know his tidy ass hat they pay
so much attention to the differentiating
each troll it's [Music] great die you're
just name as many country song or artists as
you can right now oh dude you know Dixie Chicks
okay they literally are not even called that
anymore they're just the chicks Taylor Swift
in the beginning I kind of like it but it's so
different oh they must not know that music's
supposed to make you happy there's an array of
emotions Poppy I feel bad for them it looks like
they got beat up by rainbow first things first
these trolls need some serious cheering up how
could she say that based on what she looks like
we need to sing them the most important songs in
the history of music oh no yes but which ones
all of them yo I'll tell you what I want what
I really really want I'll tell you what I want
what I want tell me what but they can't take
they can't really absorb the songs the Dogs
Out I'm just happy they started with Spice
Girls Love how apathetic they are Good Vibrations
is a great one to go to too come on let's
go yes the most important how are you going to not
do a Michael Jackson song If you're
doing King of Pop stuff for the most
important you guys don't know what pop fully is
like where's your pop history hey these songs
are great yeah but it's just recent pop you
suck whoa that's harsh they had no Madonna no
MJ no Britney no Christina and have heard
about this queen Barb and her fancy World
Tour I got to go wash what you called music
out of my ear I wish it was Dolly Parton you
in real trouble now right Aunt Delta keep an
eye on them growley Pete the solution is not
in trying to force your music onto others I knew
it who Let The Dogs Out too far okay Branch you
can say I told you so I know you want to a
it's like when religious groups go to other
lands to try to be like you should become a a
Christian here's the Bible what's that called
when they knock on your door Jehovah's maybe my
dad was right the other trolls are different in
ways I was not prepared for some trolls they
don't just want to have fun and that's okay
it's kind of like the plot of inside out but
with music instead of yeah guess we're going
home but accepting the other different
genres it ain't right to put you in jail
cuz your music's different it seems some
folks around here don't appreciate a red
medley when they hear one now that
voice I recognize what's your name
name's Hickory Branch this is Hickory
Hickory this is Branch enough with the
formalities let's go the let's yeah go
get him clamper oh my God Hickory Dickory
Dock what a lot of great moving
shots what a kinetic
[Music] mess man they did just only
improve the detail of the animation
work is also great yeah this movie does
look phenomenal we're not going to make
[Music] it classic hope pop trolls can [Music]
swim it's kind of cool too how whenever they
go into a different musical genre they also
go into a different movie genre is this why
her name is Poppy I never put that together
yeah you knew that I'm going to act like I did
yeah yeah yeah I know [Music] things what
are we looking at we found oursel this is
trippy well he's not a troll
so he must have just found his
people oh in like some other dimension yeah
maybe hi I'm really glad you came with me me
too yeah make out are woo I think we lost him we
should be all right thank you this just right on
him why are you helping us what's in it for
you hey Branch I'm sorry about my associate
I loved your message oh man oh we need to
get to the funk trolls before Barb well
quickest way is down that river guy probably
doesn't know the first thing about building a
r coffee sh
all trolls that look like me yes oh no oh no
oh
[Music] yeah oh hell [Music]
yeah happy birthday oh my God what that was the
craziest moment of the whole thing there's such
a psychedelic quality to this one so strange
are you getting a weird vibe from Hickory no
why are you I just I don't trust him well
yeah but you don't trust anybody Branch hey
I just want us to be safe do you think hickory's
trustworthy or no nope I don't it's not Hickory
you don't trust it's me I didn't say that I
thought we were friends Branch I'm starting
to think you don't even know what that means we
are friends and sometimes that means speaking up
if I think you're making a mistake that's
not the way to a girl's heart you have to
always agree with them no I just think that he
would have hated anybody oh was Hickory one of
the people who was the bounty hunters yeah
I think it was poy I can't feel my face oh
no
who they love the Jazz who does it yes
[Laughter] I love how weird this one is
hello hello it's me look Nar the Marvel's
wishes this is what happened whoa there's
no need to get sexist on us Rox it is right
I am against women Barb is going to have your
string in the world to be rid of cheesy
pointless pop music he used his saxophone
as a pole my name's Hickory and I don't
much care for smooth J well you've just
never had the chz experience the tongue
there's something provocative about it
oo gumdrops soundproof and delicious not in
your mouth who was that guy one of the many
bounty hunters out there looking for you put
us all in danger how are you supposed to save
the world if you can't even keep us safe wow
you made a pinky promise to me Queen Poppy
and you broke it no she didn't what I mean they
were almost just done for how he almost the Blu
guy if Hickory wasn't there they'd be screwed but
she's the one reason why Hickory is there oh my
God biggy left queen breaks a pinky promise she
didn't break a pinky promise what was the pinky
promise rules what do they stipulate I don't know
just that he'd be safe or something I don't know I
don't remember oh was so focused on telling you
about what a good promis keeper I am I love how
he is on his own jne this whole movie so hot
oh cool son was complaining I'm saved are you
now cuz last I checked I was a morage that's
definitely Ron funches it has to be him oh
no oh I'm done for and on top of that I
never found any trolls like me let's see
them feet step in a frame you never found
any until no this is the rock and roll
ship I don't think so Bubble Boy Something
tells me you hard ain't in this Mission
Branch what do you mean I'm here aren't I
yeah you're on the mission all right but
your heart is with Miss poppy hey Hickory
if you did tell her who knows if she'd even
hear you well let's just say only one
of you is doing the listening in this
relationship and it's not her it's you yeah
do you think that's true about her a little
bit it's hard getting out of the friendo
man the easiest way out is to never get
in have you ever been in yeah 100% %
are you kidding me I live in the friend
zone [Music]
y oh my God he got a whole civilization here
is this a disco area welcome to VI City you
are cordial guests of Prince Cooper what are
you doing here actually I'm over here how is
this possible when we were both babies my egg
got snatched out of the nest mom and dad looked
everywhere but they couldn't find me so you
guys raised me as one of your own it's like
The Prince of Egypt that fictional story I think
our search is finally over our soon it's finally
home that search is finally over you barely
search for from king and queen of funk King
Quincy and queen Essence oh it's Funk you're a
funk troll you don't have to be just one thing
I'm pop and Funk or maybe you're hip-hop like
me demonstrate yeah I think your map is a bit
outdated Do Rap God that was really smart her
map is outdated but King the queen anything
but that let's tell them how it was Prince
step let's go Funk man the variety here oh
this black and white place is amazing I've
heard this story before until the pop trolls
tried to steal our strings that's not what it
said in our scrapbooks let me tell you how it
really went down here we go and he's hip-hop
we fall asleep even on the street when we
disagre we did it on was we the of the made life
complete this actual like made up song for this
thing itans God I love the genre
Embrace remixes it is only
samples autotunes and remixes
[Music] it's cool they got an original
song in her is it I don't know I think
it is I was wondering if like with
other songs they change the lyrics too
[Music]
yeah isn't it beautiful poppy she's like
an awe the pop trolls were coming for it
all all for one and one for all so the only
way we saw what to be done leader grabbed a
single Stringer said run wa oh wa so the trolls
live in isolation because of what pop did pop
tried to destroy our music just like Barb is
trying to do damn that's a Twist history is
just going to keep repeating itself until we
make everyone realize that we're all the same
but we're not all the same it's why all our
strings are different because they reflect
our different music this is so cute denying our
differences is denying the truth of who we are
yes oh my God I hadn't thought of it like that
she is listening now so the last story was like
a story of self-acceptance and now this one's
about accepting others very true Greg very true
ass I feel like I'm watching like spiderverse
or something yeah it does kind of feel like
that actually like crazy Arab stuff no no let
me help you are you kidding me oh no cut the
P they riding dirty wow Barb I love how the
Wreckers are like um actual hovering discs
Hickory don't worry I kind of trust Hickory
yeah I changed my mind on him I can't go home
until I've proven myself as a good Queen so
that's what this is really all about why are
you so upset because your dad was right I've
been backing you up even when you ignore them
that's not how you get her to like you good
Queens actually live listen you know what I
heard back there differences do matter they do
you and me we're too different to get along no
that's not what he saying waa dude don't revert
back to who you were at the beginning of the
last movie yeah character development let's
go bro we are really different so different
completely out of Harmony completely I don't
even know why we're friends neither do I guys
why do I care about you more than anybody else
in the world he swallowed his pride and he said
it don't let him go now he just did that that
was an Olive Branch babe no go grab the Olive
Branch grab the Olive Branch don't stand there
grab the Olive Branch the Olive Branch [Music]
poppy this guy's a good singer [Music] you
it's just the [Music] JT he loves poppy
a oh all Branch she really underwater
Oh my God I don't think so he's dreaming
[Music] her [Music] feel a poor guy I
feel your brother I've been there man
hate that again only one of us lives yeah I
had like 27 years of knowing exactly how this
guy felt but that's the point until you
find your person trial and error lot of
Error 1
2 is he getting abducted by a tribe of
women hi baby your name poppy oh my God
this is how you get over her is K-pop yeah oh yes
what if you want him you're going to
have to dance for him I can't live in
a world without regon we can live in a world
without [Laughter] Kpop do you think they got
an actual Korean person to voice Decker
I do think so it' be wild if they didn't
I like that he knows every move CU he get
embrace the differences why does Barb get
to decide which music gets to be saved all music
should be saved all right okay I'm listening Paw
Patrol yeah I loved respect they both were
like yeah respect good job this is just like
the Loki season 2 finale but way better what
oh my God and also nothing like it all it's
about everyone must be saved but that's about
Loki must do it all alone stop ruining it me I
was so desperate to be a good queen that
I stopped listening to anyone but myself
including my best friend it's all because of
this stupid string no hide it hide it no no
no take the string and run as fast as you can
you hear me what what are you talking about
trust me just go there's another half I was
wondering why he had four legs oh my God oh my
God what are you doing Hickory what's going on
Hickory Run poppy [Music] Hickory oh they're the
yodelers oh no and the yers never checked in and
you were going to give our string to Barb correct
answer and you've been in back the whole time
should never have gone to your side next subject
please shut your mouth hole
please we must going to
break what the final notes of Pop I'm not going
to let you do this this is who I've been worried
about this little pipsqueak All Is Lost people get
your hands off me oh okay all right you're feisty
I respect that but you know who else was feisty
pop Village what did you do everyone everyone
no [Music] biggy oh there's not going back now we
got to murder her yeah I was just saying that she
took everybody to volcano Rock City it was scary
Rock Me Daddy I love that guy I've got to go back
we're coming with you biggy we'll never make
it past security we could overpower them with
fashion okay pop Queens rock and
roll is this going to like end in some
type of explosive finale of Music this
looks like Bowser's Castle Dam only
rock trolls are allowed back here we
are genuine hard rockers 1 2 3 4 rainbow
un everything there's all this pressure
to be a great Queen and instead of real
friends you're just surrounded by people
who just tell you what you want to hear yep
humanizer that's how it feels running real
rejects you're the best Greg music has
done nothing but divide us now that I
have the final string I can make us
all one nation of trolls under Rock
Those About to Rock We Salute You she's
just misguided it's actually a really
good villain motivation there are things
I prefer about the first one but what they
they have for the villain motivation is
really well done oh really good one cool
build all right we're going
to go Barracuda on their
asses [Music] it sounds like pink to me
dude Jam [Applause] Barracuda give it
up for your former leaders Funk country
Technic classical worst of all pop a she's being
booed who wants to see what the ultimate
power cord can do does it see or here what
what would it do it how [Music] would it's her
boyfriend I guess a giant comprehensive manual
does come in handy just in time it's
a weird entering line too late Branch
[Music] wait oh
wow it turned him into a rock she doesn't even
know what she did no break out oh my God he's
reborn rock girls love a bad boy though
you're turning everyone into rock zombies
yep yo this is not cool man it's mullet
time
no yo it's not a bad look who wants to party
without smiling feel like this
gives a bad name to rock and
roll wow amazing performance oh oh fight
it she winked she winked what are you
doing you're supposed to be a rock song
me see gum drops gum drops and she did it
with her eyes too a world where everyone
looks the same and sounds the same that's
not Harmony hey Barb that's Nazism maybe
Queen poppy has a point if we all look
the same act the same dress the same how
will anyone know we're cool yep took you
this long to realizes a good Queen listens
real Harmony takes lots of voices different
voices do you know what you just did
though yeah it's a blend yeah but she made
everybody gray I know now share the color
no you got to repair the strings my strings
they're not your strings to claim you've
destroyed music give it up everybody thanks
to the Queen of Pop Madonna history repeats
itself pop has ruined everything oh no they got
to perform together and that's how you restore
music the music comes from within the
soul that's right let it out perform
it's a beat right
[Music] there
nice it's cool how the
second one is actually about
music oh that's beautiful they all could
have turned on poppy but they didn't Queen
Bob can't take away always something that is
inside us exactly because that's where music
really comes from but now it comes from us it's
an expression listen to that barb can't take that
away I have chel Beau is
just awesome start singing s
Me O nipple chills
[Music]
a these [Music] two best color Dad it's all
right Barbara just let everyone be what they
want to be including you he's like The Beetles
how come it wasn't expressed to your daughter
earlier let moving see me do it like nobody else
this is so adorable yeah but this is a pop song
so it's all the sounds combined
kind of but does that sound like
country to you or Rock to you no
it sounds like pop is prevailing
but it's [Music] nice I'll let it
slide but it's 100% a pop song it's
not stand and it's just a big
[Music] collaboration oh hell yeah there
some goodlooking trolls I want the yoders
come on [Music] yoders beautiful
the classics have been restored
1 2 3 and four let's go everybody
get on the floor your soul I want
you to reach with your elbow I cannot
wait to see this cast oh yes Cloud get
it come on Barb embrace
it let's go Mohawk oh it's
different colors her hair
yeah yeah you can only fight Darkness with
light I should have listen to what you had
to say and not run off like that I'm so glad
you didn't listen to me you were brave enough
to believe things can change feel like
the lesson here is don't listen to your
parents No it should be listen hear them
out but now that you're not forcing me I
hope we can be friends yes did you hear that
Carol we have a girl group now Branch I love
that we're different here it comes and I love
you Queen Poppy I love you to Branch a shall
we now that's a good connection but like
romantically yeah you have to be able to
listen to other voices even when they don't
agree with you depends who you're talking
to so whether your song is sad and heartfelt
or warm and funky or even if you're a little
bit of each yeah it's all these sounds and
all our differences that make the world your
place I love this message right now I'm
done with my nap and I'm ready to party
glitter okay I am glued to these credits
I know I am ready for the cast to come up
so you can freak out let go let's go
oh only took five writers I get why
and one of them was last name Burger
which is like buron which is the first
one isn't that what they were called a solid
observations yeah relevant based on the good
luck trolls created by Thomas dam is that just the
troll dolls just like the executive M producer gon
theore okay Anna Kendrick this we knew Justin
Timberly this we knew Rachel Bloom no way James
Cordon that we knew I can't believe that was
Rachel Bloom and I didn't pull that Ron F okay
damn his voice is so distinct Kell K Clarkson
good call no but I thought Kelly clar was the
other person Anders right yeah I thought it was
pink or Kelly Sam Rockell oh my God we should have
been able to pull that with George Clinton wow
I I'm feeling very and Mary I'm feeling very bad
about myself right now very bad about myself iort
this feel Thompson who does he play Jay Balin well
I missed some of this Fula Borg this is wow this
cast Aussie Osborne shut STFU oh who's the dad oh
Anthony Ramos that's cool wow wow these mov just
have such star studded voices damn okay now I can
actually talk about it now that I know how bad I
was wait who who played the person that I couldn't
believe that I didn't know that who played it
Rachel Bloom that's crazy that's crazy that's
nut that's crazy you know what else is crazy that
if you guys are listening to this on Apple and
Spotify would just listen to watch trolls World
Tour and Roxy finally has a real reject shirt
I do I have a real reject shirt which I'm stoked
about because I'm a reject do you know what's the
store is called yeah it's called you already know
it's right here no one here remembers the name of
the store why would I know the name of the store
no one remembers it it's reject naations shop.com
that's the first time you've ever said it in front
of me yeah that's not true yes I think so that's
impossible so we pull it reject naations shop.com
reject naations shop.com you guess sure's like
this space babies the Galaxy also got our Pedro
Pascal chop protection services shirt top seller
we got a whole bunch of other te's and is one of
the best ways to support the channel personally my
favorite way to support the channel when are you
oh griffy I guess we're late to the party a balls
gy but who's going to eat my cheese balls babe
they're back he said balls I know I love balls
when are you going to make a purge daddy shirt
let's see how relevant that's that quote stays
forever I think it will damn okay so get your
shirts get a shirt guys get a shirt which was you
could find that reject naations shop.com reject
naations shop.com all right guys we are starting
trollstopia this television show available on
peacock season one episode one right now oh I
didn't even know this was a thing apparently um
this franchise is surprisingly good I don't know
why I'm surprised by it but I just didn't think
when we started this I was going to be in into
it and by the second one I'm like they do just
a phenomenal job differentiating these two like
you talked about a little bit throughout from
within to how you see the world uh I think it
has really beautiful powerful messages and on
top of all of the well written stuff it looks
effing amazing it does look effing amazing it
does did you prefer to Ser of the firsters what
do I don't think so I think that well you know
what interestingly enough I feel like the first
hit me at a good time in my life for that message
and this one is hitting me at a good time in my
life for that message like yeah I think that you
need the first one first right because it does
start from within and knowing that bringing other
people down doesn't bring you happiness happiness
comes from within and you have to find that in
your soul and yourself and do the work but then
also once you do that then you're ready for this
one which is making sure that you don't then put
that on other people every everybody needs to
feel how I feel everybody needs to look how I
look everybody needs to see the world how I see
the world have the preferences I have otherwise
we can't be friends so it's like I feel they did
this in the right order and so while the first one
I think I I give the slight Edge to because
I thought that I was going to hate it and I
didn't this one is almost I would say equally as
good just the first one surprised me more what
about you uh in terms of which one did I pref
like do I like this one more than the last one
did you forget the question you had asked
me because I had such a long-winded answer
yeah and I was so invested and when you speak I
listen that's a a very big lesson to this one I'm
I'm like Branch I like because I'm like Branch
I'm like Branch I am Groot I like I like things
about this one more I think overall I prefer
the first one there's there's definitely PR I
mean there's definitely things about the first
one that I prefer I think the overall story of
the first one I prefer like I found myself really
invested in like the a personal Journey between
branch and Poppy and then when they got the
girl who they I forget her name that was that
the Zoe Edition character right which one the two
trolls the berens that we saw at the end here oh
yeah yeah like when they may yeah when we got to
them I I think I think you're right I think it
is Bridget yeah like that storyline I was just
so invested into but what I really loved about
this was I think most of the time with animated
movies when they do a sequel they up the uh the
quality of the animation but they didn't just
up the quality they they added like a different
layer to it the texture was a lot more defined it
felt a a lot more tangible yet way more expressive
and trippy and Vivid and wild and eccentric as
super imaginative I thought the camera work was
awesome I love the versatility throughout and I
like that this one was like the last one's like
yeah I mean music was a part of it for sure um
but this one was solely about music yeah and
about the preservation of music but using that as
an allegory to be able to have a conversation and
and then someone who's had a week and you've
had many many weeks of this uh for something
much more real than a than a silly Marvel movie
um just like you can't like I'm always about I I
like to be able to have conversations with people
I like to be able to heat for the Marvel movie oh
God yeah that's wild isn't it crazy how much you
could get heat for not liking something oh yeah
no matter how Nuance of a conversation you try
to have people just immediately you're dealing
with the internet you have like a black and white
thinking and like you obviously there's like real
world stuff happening right and and uh it's to
have just a conversation with people a lot of
the time because a lot of times people throw
their own biases in there about anything you
know and and the subjects I'm referring to I've
had my conversations with people too and it is
it is just like I just want to like talk I just
want to be able to talk even if we don't see eye
to eye I want to be able to talk and so I love
the message of this one in a day and age where
people don't seem to know how to just um accept
different perspectives a lot of the time it's cool
to to convey that to especially to kids who grow
up in a world of social media where the instant
reaction to things cuz like that's something
I was thinking about I hate how communication
gets so lost on the internet and like you and I
are old enough to know of a time before social
media ever existed and there's kids who grow up
in a world where that is how they're going to
learn to communicate is how people treat each
other on Twitter and Facebook and comments and
stuff you know with missing the the Nuance of a
conversation and that's why I love the message
here of being able to accept others in a way of
knowing that it's it's everyone's differences is
a big part of what gives strength you know and
and like that's that's why I love like all the
people who come here on this channel and that's
why I ever try to like change anyone I'm like no
because of what you what makes you different
like do that you know as much as I want Roxy
to like love certain movies that I love and I
know she's going to get crap for it I'm like
what well better you than me Roxy you take the
that is the lesson of this yeah I do like even
sometimes like they're multiple lessons from
the same event right even the even the troll
and this the rock and roll guy who's like uh how
are we going to be cool if everybody looks like us
and that is the truth you don't want a million 's
running around because then you're not special and
unique exactly but also you don't want a million
use running around because then you're not your
best self and also because it doesn't create as
good of a world interesting of life or celebrate
people's culture so I like that that we had even
random Side characters kind of throwing in these
lines that hopefully cause because this is a kids
movie right it's a kid movie that we can enjoy as
adults but hopefully when people are listening to
this it number one introduces them to different
genres of music because a lot of kids you know
you grow up in whatever house you grow up in I
grew up in a house that listened to rock and roll
that's what we did I grew up in a rock and roll
family uh and so it was always cool when you went
to your friend's house and they put on different
kind of music you know you're learning about
that so I like that this kind of introduces you
to different things and then it does have some
really heartwarming messages about the kind of
people that you're connecting with and and being
able to like you said have Nuance conversations
but see the world differently and love each other
regardless yeah and I think that they did a really
beautiful job of this I I am curious what their
perspective on the listening situation is because
it's like we hear over and over again that Poppy's
not listening to people mhm but then at the end
of it her dad's like I'm glad you don't listen to
me and then I was like interesting yeah that's an
interesting take uh I think that hopefully people
can take away the lesson like it's important to
listen to everybody and then still make your own
educated decision after you've listened listening
doesn't mean that you're going to do what they
say just means you take it into consideration
but then at the end when her dad's like I'm glad
you didn't listen I'm like H well I think it's the
I I I think it's the manner in in going about the
matter is what that moment was ultimately trying
to convey if that makes sense like she still
apologizes for not having listened like she
went behind his back so she still apologizes for
the action and while he was glad that ultimately
she didn't listen there still got the apology and
the and her taking the accountability of maybe
there could have been a further elaboration
of like I should have ran this by you first
completely it's not I didn't ruin the movie for
me at all I just when I'm of all the lessons that
did land that one was kind of like H I wonder
what this movie think about listening to your
parents I mean that's kind of a weird message
that I think a lot of animated movies now kind
of say is you form your own identity don't listen
to your parents which is not like in a nuanced way
there's it's not bad you know like if I just form
my identity soly off my parents I'd be more of a
mess than I already am you know so I get it like
I totally understand uh it is just interesting
that we live in a time where animated movies are
often conveying like pix hard kind of does that
a lot it's like your parents put that movie on
for you yeah like like we watched Brave here and
they did kind of something similar I think yeah
wow people loved that one and you and I felt who
we don't need to do that hey it's okay look do
fine just please stick to the love yeah well I
what I would say is that I'm excited for a third
one of this I think that I would definitely want
to see whatever they come up with we went from we
will bring a camera to the theater are we going
to watch it record ourselves no no no we'll wait
we'll wait we'll experience every what's it called
it's called trolls Nation it is band together
that's not what you said I did say band together
did you yeah I said band together wow good job
I just gasl you I know you do you do that o I
love Andrew who's Andre and D Diggs whoa damn D
Diggs is a big pull my Thompson was Tiny diamond
for Tone's going to be in it yeah we know that
because we know that uh in sync got back together
for hot on a reunion oh to do trolls they were
reuning for that so I think it's the whole I
think it's all of them I'm not sure though
somebody tell me I heard say something on hot
ones about it that's even cooler because Justin
Timberlake is still successful without them and
then they got back together because it'd be one
thing if his career went down to tube and then
he did it but but the fact that he's still like
a superstar yeah it's like why does that happen
man like all I want is for Kelly and Michelle
to be with Beyonce by her side still and like
to go see a child performance like if Beyonce did
that now it would be so cool but if she waits for
her career to die then it's not as cool do you
know whose career is never going to die Beyonce
yeah I know it's never going to die I'm not even
that into Beyonce but I'd love to go to a Beyonce
concert yeah I mean it's like her and Taylor
Swift right those are the two biggest performers
currently on the planet I think that's right well
like opening up yourself I mean talking about the
differences I'm I'm smoothly finding my way back
into this did you think Keenan Thompson was M
lemore or who did you think was M I was joking I
didn't think any of them were Lally not a white
guy that was the joke I was naming white rappers
and I don't think you picked up on it who was
the one you said before Eminem atmosphere oh um
anyway but yeah like uh the diff like I used to
not like listening to Taylor Swift um I I could
never get into her music and then when the aist
to started rolling around I was like you know I
bought tickets so maybe I should try listening I
still couldn't get into her music really and then
I was like I was exercising and then Spotify Auto
played a song and I didn't and I was like that's
a cool song let me hit the like button so I could
add it and I didn't know I was listening to a
Taylor Swift song and I was like whoa remember
it's called I did something bad from the album
reputation okay and I was like this is a dope
song maybe I can like Taylor's Swift and maybe my
heart's just been this whole like thing of have I
just been resisting this entire time and you feel
like that's like the troll and I've been listening
to Taylor Swift like every single day since and
went to the ays tour and then even today actually
like I I uh and then watching the documentary and
like open up my mind and that's what I mean like
I've I love having that and a lot of times I find
myself like kind of judgmental of a subject or any
little thing and I'll question like wait why am
I judging that let me inquire a little bit more
and so I'm on a big so so yeah I really I think
this message really hit home for me but in terms
of like narratively it it was more of like a
great visual feast and like great music and
stuff and it was more of like the surface things
with message I really liked the emotionality of
the first one hit me better I would say you know
what I mean like the actual story itself hit me
better yeah I agree with you yeah I'm reading
trolls band together synopsis are you mad you
do that okay but can you I am livid I am fuming
poppy discovers that Branch was once part of the
boy band brozone with his brothers Floyd oh my God
is it going to be all of them clay it must be and
Floyd is kidnapped branch and Poppy embark on a
journey to reunite his two brother other brothers
and rescue Floyd tell tell me that doesn't sound
amazing is it gonna be can you imagine branch in
a br Zone band is is is it going to be are they
going to sing like like an N Sync song I I think
that's what they're back together for are they
going to do like bye bye bye that' be amazing
I think they I think they have a new song coming
for I don't care about their new songs you don't
play the ones I know wow when you go to a Chili
Peppers concert or you like play the one from
the new we or you like no literally never to kill
fornications it's like when you meet somebody and
they're like my favorite song is Danny California
and you're like oh okay I'm sorry why that's your
favorite it's not my favorite no I love that song
no yeah I do love that album I do I mean at least
it's not the newest newest but still okay anyway
but you get what I mean I get what you mean yo
dude look I gotta make make sure you get out of
here on time we're cutting it close and I know so
we got to go um and what would you rate it what
would you rate it out of what out of uh 100 what
would I rate trolls around the world out of 100
World Tour World Tour World Tour 100 what would
you rate it don't just follow me no I'm trying
to think okay out of a 100 I would give it an uh
an 85 out of 10 I would give it an 8.5 I think I
would do a little higher than that probably like
an 87 all right all right that's what I'd rate it
what would you rate US let us know that's what I
want to know I want I wanted I want people to
talk about us specifically yeah that's leave a
comment thanks rejects um pick up the shirts like
this video wear your pants right below your chest
that's the way to do it I don't know what to
tell you it's just where they go where it goes
when I stand it goes lower but as I'm sitting
and I'm I'm a climbing monkey so like what
do you want from me okay well from here on out
this is how I'm going to do all videos okay bye
bye that's good that's where it looks best
this is for the [Laughter] [Music] sink